how's it going bros I am a Rick and
Morty fan I have an IQ of at least a
thousand decimal decimal for I am an
Rick and Morty fan very high and without
a solid grasp of theoretical physics
most of the jokes will go over the
difficult years head as consequence
people who dislike what the money truly
are idiots of course they wouldn't
appreciate for instance the humor in
Rick's existential catchphrase
wobba wobba duh duh
life is meaningless grab a beloved
dubbed app left us the point i'm pick a
brick [ __ ] you see Rick and Morty it's
not just an adult cartoon it says
something deep about life they say
something deep about life adult car - I
don't give a mother [ __ ] don't give a
[ __ ] IQ to 42nd boy holy you idiot
me when I deal with the whole crew like
oh I know but you will never be yes you
will never matter its alecky wait if I
mess the brains but you look like six oh
one last thing
you